Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je vous invite à un sursaut collectif !
Un sursaut vital, comme on va le voir.
Depuis dix ans, je fais un travail
de prospective multidisciplinaire
consacré aux vulnérabilités
des sociétés modernes.
En gros,
j'analyse les « problèmes systémiques »
auxquels l'humanité fait face
et élabore des propositions pour traiter
ces problématiques,
en éliminant les fausses bonnes idées
– ce qui ne peut pas marcher,
c'est-à-dire...
la quasi-intégralité de ce qu'on nous
présente comme des « solutions ».
Je vais vous livrer mon analyse, et vous
comprendrez pourquoi je dors mal la nuit !
Dans l'exposé qui vient,
je vais énoncer les principaux
défis auxquels l'humanité est confrontée,
j'expliquerai pourquoi les stratégies
dont on dispose pour s'attaquer
au changement climatique,
aux enjeux d'énergie, de ressources
ou de sécurité alimentaire par exemple,
pourquoi ces stratégies sont
fondamentalement inadaptées
parce qu'elles passent
à côté du problème principal.
Puis je formulerai
quelques propositions pour inspirer,
j'espère, des actes
constructifs et pertinents
en matière de réflexion comme d'action.
Nous vivons dans des décors
que nous nous sommes construits.
Des décors urbains pour la plupart,
qui occultent la nature,
mais aussi socioculturels et idéologiques
qui anesthésient notre lien à la nature.
L'envers de nos décors est un enfer
pour toutes les formes de vie,
qui tentent de nous survivre.
Comme je vais le démontrer,
notre civilisation
est une mégamachine
d'annihilation du vivant.
Soit nous enrayons cette machine folle,
soit nous nous autodétruirons, emportant
avec nous une myriade d'espèces.
Une autodestruction possiblement imminente
étant donné les vulnérabilités
de nos sociétés.
Nos sociétés sont clivées entre ceux
qui compris que le monde
a atteint ses limites physiques
et que nous devons redéfinir
nos comportements,
et ceux qui rejettent
– en général par principe,
sans avoir étudié la question –
l'idée même de limites :
soit ils nient les limites du monde,
soit ils les reconnaissent
mais croient en l'absence de limite
à la capacité de l'Homme
à résoudre les problèmes.
Cette foi inconditionnelle est un déni.
Croire qu'on peut trouver des solutions
– donc maintenir le système,
pas en changer –
c'est chercher
à faire durer le non-durable.
Il faut saisir que la question des
limites et vulnérabilités sociétales
n'est ni une discussion idéologique,
ni affaire d'opinion ou
d'intuition personnelle.
En réalité,
les dynamiciens des systèmes,
les experts de la résilience
des infrastructures,
les spécialistes des cycles
biogéochimiques, les écologues,
montrent que le monde est
un système régi par des rétroactions,
effets de seuil,
effets domino, effets rebond,
et qu'à cause de processus exponentiels,
on a un souci de timing :
les approches d'il y a vingt ans
ne sont plus adaptées.
En réalité, il est trop tard pour un
quelconque « développement durable ».
Et nulle stratégie ne permettra de dégager
des perspectives enviables et viables
tant qu'on ne considérera pas
le problème pour ce qu'il est :
un vice de notre modèle de civilisation.
Je vous invite à le visualiser via une
analyse systémique de la situation.
Le monde naturel se compose
de six « sphères ».
La première c'est la lithosphère,
l'enveloppe rigide de la Terre.
On en extrait les hydrocarbures
sur lesquels repose
la civilisation industrielle,
les métaux dont les terres rares,
le sable de construction,
des nutriments vitaux
comme le phosphore, etc.
Et toutes ces choses
butent sur des limites.
C'est une question de stocks parfois,
mais souvent plutôt de flux :
peut-on assurer les approvisionnements
– en pétrole notamment –
dont nos sociétés ont perpétuellement
besoin pour fonctionner ?
La deuxième sphère c'est l'hydrosphère,
l'ensemble des eaux de la planète :
océans, mers, lacs, cours d'eau,
nappes phréatiques.
Elle est dans un état
de dégradation avancée :
pollutions,
plastiques et autres déchets,
acidification, réchauffement,
montée des eaux, salinisation,
assèchement, zones mortes :
tous les voyants sont au rouge.
Troisième sphère : la cryosphère,
les glaces de la planète :
banquises, inlandsis,
glaciers, permafrost.
J'ai un scoop :
ça fond !
Et le processus s'accélère.
La quatrième sphère, c'est l'atmosphère.
On altère sa composition si vite
que les cycles de l'eau et du carbone
– essentiels à la vie –
sont totalement détraqués.
Le climat sort de sa zone de stabilité...
Sans compter les multiples
pollutions en gaz et en particules.
Cinquième sphère : la biosphère,
l'ensemble du vivant.
Là, c'est une tragédie effroyable
qui est en train de se dérouler
derrière nos jolis décors.
Si on exclut l'humanité
et les animaux d'élevage,
60% des vertébrés ont disparu en 44 ans.
Des vertébrés !
Ça inclut les mammifères
terrestres et marins,
les amphibiens, les poissons,
les reptiles et les oiseaux.
Si on n'entend pas le cri
que nous adresse la nature...
Entendons-nous bien :
les êtres vivants ne
« disparaissent » pas :
nous les exterminons !
Par nos modes de vie.
Ce n'est pas un procès
d'intention, juste un fait.
Sixième et dernière sphère du monde
naturel, la pédosphère : les sols.
75% des terres de la planète
sont dans un état critique
dû aux pratiques agricoles
intensives, à l'urbanisation
ou aux activités industrielles,
notamment minières.
Et dernièrement, les Nations unies
nous ont alertés
d'un risque majeur de pénurie
alimentaire mondiale.
Voilà l'état constaté du monde naturel.
Vous voyez pourquoi je dors mal parfois...
À côté de cela, il y a la septième
sphère, l'anthroposphère :
l'humanité, les activités
et les productions humaines
– constructions, objets, déchets.
L'anthroposphère explose :
un boom exponentiel qui fait que
l'empreinte écologique humaine
– la pression qu'on exerce
sur la planète –
surpasse désormais ce que
cette dernière peut encaisser.
Question :
nos sociétés peuvent-elles durer
quand partout le monde naturel s'effondre
ou bute sur des limites ?
Non.
Une grande descente énergétique
et matérielle s'amorce,
ponctuée de pannes logistiques
et de pénuries.
Il faut s'y préparer,
apprendre à vivre en équilibre avec
cette nature dont nous faisons partie.
Si l'on se croit invincible
et qu'on ne se prépare pas,
des effondrements se produiront
bientôt un peu partout :
des processus confus au bout desquels
nous devrons assurer nos besoins
élémentaires par nous-mêmes.
Pour bien comprendre
la nature de nos vulnérabilités,
j'ajoute à ce panorama
quatre éléments.
Un :
tout ce qu'on fait requiert
le fonctionnement
continu de chaînes logistiques
à flux tendu hors de notre contrôle,
qui nécessitent des transports,
dont 96% utilisent du pétrole.
Si vous croyez la sécurité
alimentaire, énergétique
ou sanitaire assurée par l'État,
les collectivités, c'est faux :
en cas de rupture logistique prolongée,
nous sommes livrés à nous-mêmes.
Deux : on dépend d'infrastructures :
réseaux de transports, télécoms,
eau, gaz, électricité,
qui tous nécessitent un apport permanent
de matériaux et d'énergie pour leur bon
fonctionnement et leur maintenance.
Trois : on a technologisé le monde,
mais ce faisant,
certes on l'a optimisé, mais on l'a
surtout complexifié... et fragilisé.
Nous voici vulnérables
à des ruptures d'approvisionnement,
des pannes,
des hackers, des cyberterroristes, etc.
Et quatre :
la crise sur le gâteau :
Nous sommes à la merci
de marchés boursiers instables.
Notre monde entier est inféodé
à un système financier courtermiste
dont la finalité est à l'antipode
de l'intérêt général.
Alors,
on fait quoi ?
On réclame que les dirigeants agissent ?
Peine perdue :
quand bien même
ils le voudraient sincèrement,
leurs réponses sont inadaptées !
Pour s'en convaincre,
jetons un œil du côté du climat
– la question qui mobilise
la communauté internationale :
on a un sommet onusien annuel,
des milliards investis,
un marché du carbone,
on a des innovations
– des cleantech, greentech, smarttech –
des transitions énergétiques
dans x pays et...
nulle réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Zéro !
Zéro.
Pourquoi ?
Déjà parce qu'on brigue
la croissance économique,
ce qui élève l'empreinte écologique.
Nul découplage, par exemple,
entre PIB et gaz à effet de serre
à l'échelle mondiale.
Mais surtout
– et c'est là le cœur de mon propos –
même si nous arrivions à éviter
un dérèglement climatique cataclysmique
en décarbonant la civilisation,
nous n'empêcherions quand même pas
un effondrement global.
Parce que nos réponses sont inadaptées :
parce que l'on traite le dérèglement
du climat comme un problème,
alors que ce n'en est pas un :
c'est un symptôme !
Modélisons la situation :
en amont, on prélève des ressources ;
au milieu, on les transforme
en biens et en services ;
en aval, on rejette
des déchets et pollutions.
Ceux-ci sont
solides, liquides ou gazeux,
et parmi les gaz,
il y a les gaz à effet de serre.
Les dérèglements climatiques
sont un des effets secondaires
du fait que cette civilisation est un
flux irréversible – non circularisable –
qui convertit la nature en déchets.
Et donc de l'énergie – même décarbonée –
au service de cette civilisation,
c'est un maintien de ce flux qui mutile
les conditions de vie sur Terre.
La transition énergétique, par exemple,
pour fonctionner,
ne peut être, déjà,
qu'un décroissement,
puis surtout elle doit s'intégrer
dans une vaste palette de stratégies
s'attaquant aux causes
primaires, c'est-à-dire...
visant à changer de civilisation.
Alors je comprends bien
qu'il est difficile d'imaginer que
nos représentations de l'avenir
sont obsolètes.
Personnellement, ça ne
favorise pas mon sommeil.
Mais soit nous ouvrons une conversation
pour décider ensemble de ce qu'on préserve
et de ce qu'on fait évoluer,
de ce qu'on arrête
et de ce qu'on crée,
et nous pouvons encore aménager
un avenir vivable et digne...
soit on ne se prépare pas
et ces choix vont nous être imposés
sous le prétexte de la sécurité
dans des contextes
sérieusement liberticides.
Et le moment du choix,
qu'on le veuille ou non, c'est maintenant.
Pas demain : maintenant.
C'est le déclic ou le déclin.
Je repose donc la question :
on fait quoi ?
Eh bien, on garde espoir !
Mais pas n'importe lequel !
Pas l'espoir simpliste
qui consiste à présupposer
qu'ils résoudront le problème !
Pas l'espoir non plus de pérenniser
cette civilisation toxique et mourante !
Celui d'inventer d'autres
façons d'être au monde.
Il faut déconstruire les faux espoirs
pour pouvoir construire
des espoirs lucides !
Or les verrouillages du système
excluent la solution top-down :
il faut agir par en dessous.
C'est à nous de jouer !
C'est comme ça, ça tombe sur nous.
Chacun est responsable de l'avenir,
même si non coupable du passé.
Et ce sont nos choix qui vont
nous déterminer, nous définir.
Serons-nous ceux qui se seront levés
pour cette cause qui pèse
sur toutes les autres ?
Ou serons-nous ceux
qui s'en seront lavé les mains ?
Ne nous abandonnons pas
à la résignation,
au désespoir, au défaitisme !
L'avenir sera ce qu'on en fera.
Et la bonne nouvelle
– ça y est, j'y viens ! –
c'est qu'il existe mille
façons constructives d'agir !
Deux grands chantiers s'imposent :
une révolution de la pensée,
un réveil des actes.
Premier chantier :
décoloniser et réinvestir nos imaginaires.
C'est la sphère n°8, la sphère des idées.
Pour commencer, mobilisons nos créativités
pour élaborer des contre-récits inspirants
aptes à supplanter le récit
dominant du sans-limite,
une escroquerie loufoque
génératrice de rapports
de force oppressifs
qui nous voue à des dissonances
cognitives brisant tout bien-être.
Chacun doit dès maintenant comprendre
que loin de s'opposer,
loin d'être rivales,
lutte sociale et lutte écologique
peuvent et doivent se renforcer.
Il est temps de fonder
de nouvelles cultures
basées sur d'autres
hiérarchies de valeurs.
Ok, ça paraît un peu abstrait comme ça...
mais en réalité
presque tout existe déjà :
agroécologie, agroforesterie,
permaculture,
maraîchage sur sol vivant,
circuits courts, locavorisme,
coopératives d'habitants,
réappropriation citoyenne des Communs
– l'air, l'eau, le sol, les graines –
monnaies locales, systèmes
d'échanges locaux, low-tech, etc.
Il existe plein de choses à faire
pour vivre mieux et durablement.
Renseignez-vous !
Formez-vous, transformez-vous !
Ces apprentissages et réinventions
requièrent quelques efforts
mais ils sont profondément libérateurs.
Et dorénavant, demandons-nous,
pour chaque chose qu'on fait :
est-ce que ça participe à revitaliser
la nature et les rapports humains ?
Cette question doit devenir le réflexe.
Posez-vous cette question.
Outre ce chantier des imaginaires,
le second grand chantier
concerne nos actes.
C'est la neuvième sphère :
la sphère du faire.
Deux types d'actes, complémentaires :
la Résistance et la Résilience.
Tout d'abord brisons
ces décors qui nous hypnotisent
et entrons en Résistance
contre la mégamachine !
Les petits pas et gestes quotidiens,
c'est bien, mais on n'en est plus là.
Stopper la destruction, contrer
la violence inouïe de cette civilisation
est une question de légitime défense
autant qu'une question éthique.
Mobilisations citoyennes,
désobéissance civique :
on a besoin de chacune et de chacun,
d'actes emblématiques.
Que « l'activisme » soit votre truc
ou pas, écoutez, faut y aller, là !
C'est une guerre !
Je sais que mes propos
contrastent avec votre décor.
Pourtant ils ne sont
ni dogmatiques, ni excessifs
– en fait, ils sont assez banals chez
les experts des sciences naturelles.
C'est notre arrière-décor
qui est extrême !
À ce stade, la réponse
proportionnée aux enjeux
c'est de se mobiliser avec détermination !
Ensemble, stoppons
les activités nuisibles,
les projets fous,
les élites quand elles sont
perverties ou cupides,
les multinationales, banques,
cabinets d'avocats, lobbys
au service d'intérêts privés
contre l'intérêt général.
Il faut dire STOP à ces choses-là !
Si nous ne le faisons pas,
qui ?
À nous d'inverser les rapports de force,
d'être architectes
et non plus simples figurants
de l'avenir.
Et si États et décideurs
ont un rôle à jouer dorénavant,
c'est un rôle de facilitation
de démarches de résilience.
Un bon leader, là, ce serait quoi ?
Ce serait un visionnaire mobilisé
au service d'un projet d'avenir
qui soit cohérent, inspirant,
d'intérêt général.
Ces premiers actes dessinent
le contour de la Résistance.
À côté de cela, il y a la Résilience :
montrer qu'on peut vivre
différemment et bien
sans dépendre de chaînes
d'approvisionnement
de l'autre bout du monde
ou de systèmes industriels
hypercapitalistiques,
ou de dispositifs techniques
ultrasophistiqués.
Vivre et travailler avec la nature
sans chercher à la dominer,
avec respect.
Créer de la cohésion durable.
Devenir collectivement
moins fragiles face aux limites.
Fondons de nouvelles sociétés
en parallèle de ce système insensé,
des sociétés qui prendront
le relai demain,
libérées de la course au toujours-plus
et sachant s'autolimiter
de façon digne et solidaire.
Construisons des alternatives inspirantes.
Et un conseil : si vous pensez pouvoir
devenir autonome dans votre coin
ou créer une communauté isolée
avec un potager, des réserves,
et peut-être une culture défensive,
ça ne tiendra pas dans la durée,
je vous le dis. Même si vous êtes riche !
Inspirez-vous plutôt de l'esprit
du mouvement des Villes en Transition.
Ça ne suffit pas mais c'est le début.
Il ne s'agit pas non plus d'ignorer
le risque d'insécurité,
mais d'instaurer des dynamiques
constructives de coopération, en réseaux.
La Résilience ne peut qu'être collective :
pas des îlots dispersés
mais des archipels reliés,
complémentaires et solidaires,
pour rendre les territoires résilients
c'est-à-dire aptes à gérer
la descente énergétique et matérielle
tout en assurant aux gens
des conditions de vie décentes.
Qui que vous soyez,
contribuez à votre façon !
Vous avez du temps ? De l'argent ?
Donnez-en pour des projets
de régénération d'écosystèmes !
Vous avez des terres ?
Invitez-y des alternatives
qui préparent l'après-pétrole !
Vous êtes élu ?
Ouvrez votre territoire à des projets
de transition socio-écologique :
les gens s'organiseront, vous n'avez rien
à faire, juste leur faciliter la tâche.
Vous êtes patron ? Réorientez l'entreprise
avec un business model
réellement soutenable !
Qu'employés et employeurs
mènent ensemble
des projets de long terme
vecteurs de sens !
Vous êtes une école ?
Préparez les élèves à la Résilience
plutôt qu'à un marché du travail
qui d'ici quelques années
aura totalement changé !
Et cetera.
Il y a tant à faire !
Un raz-de-marée d'initiatives
de Résilience doit déferler !
Et ça ne tient qu'à nous.
Devant nous,
c'est un projet de civilisation !
Et tout part de nous.
Ça ne doit pas nous intimider
mais nous motiver ! Car de beaux,
de grands moments se profilent
si nous dépassons
les dénis, les hypocrisies,
les décors.
Si nous œuvrons ensemble
avec dignité et détermination,
nous pouvons encore faire prévaloir les
forces de vie contre les forces de mort.
Avant de conclure,
un avertissement relatif à la technologie
vu qu'on est ici dans un cadre
plutôt technophile :
la technologie, elle nous fascine...
mais c'est un outil,
et il est bénéfique s'il émancipe
et ne nous transforme pas en junkies,
et s'il participe à une
décomplexification du monde
au lieu d'ajouter de la complexité
qui nous rend dépendants
et nous vulnérabilise.
La complexité mène à la perplexité.
La perspicacité invite à la simplicité.
Sur une planète sursaturée,
la technologie n'a de sens
qu'au service d'un grand projet
pour l'avènement d'autres modes de vie
qui soient protecteurs
et non plus exploiteurs de la nature.
Renouvellement des imaginaires,
Résistance, Résilience :
tout est là !
C'est la clef.
Si après m'avoir entendu,
vous ignorez comment démarrer,
voici mon conseil
– il s'applique à n'importe qui :
organisez dès que possible
des conversations dans votre entourage,
communauté, voisinage,
résidence, entreprise :
des réunions physiques
pour discuter ensemble
des limites et des vulnérabilités,
des ressources,
des richesses culturelles
qui sont les vôtres.
Vous rencontrerez d'autres gens concernés
et trouverez des réponses concrètes
à la question que vous devez
tous poser dorénavant :
que peut-on faire pour vivifier
notre communauté et la nature
et pour tendre vers
l'autosuffisance territoriale ?
Faites ça :
vous ferez naître des espoirs lucides.
Accessoirement,
je dormirai mieux...
et nous dormirons tous mieux, je crois.
Par avance, merci !
(Applaudissements)